Oh, my goodness.
Can you come up here and I'll give you
my opinion here?
Let's do this.
Here, you can come up and I'll give you
my opinion.
You're supposedly a Christian, are you?
Okay.
We got my friend Victor here, good,
finally.
Hey Victor, you there?
Yes, yes. Can you hear me? Yeah, what's
your religious background?
I'm Christian Orthodox.
Then you're not supposed to be with
non-Christians.
Yeah.
Why are you with her? How long you been
with her?
Uh approximately 1 year.
You've been in sin and your priest has
not thrown you out of the church yet?
Uh no, he doesn't know.
Your priest doesn't know?
No.
So, you haven't gone to confession and
told your priest that you're in sin? Cuz
you can't take communion.
Yeah, but uh
what if
I was thinking like what I Yeah, I was
thinking that she would uh change, you
know. I know, I know, I know. Yeah, so
yeah, because, you know, I know the
future. God made me a prophet, so I see
in the future that she's going to become
Christian.
I don't know like that.
Well, uh because you're saying what if
what if and what if not and then on top
of that your fornication, you're
committing fornication.
You're committing sin. You're in sexual
sin and you think God is okay with that?
Jesus, she's a Muslima, let me sleep
with her before marriage and then she'll
become Christian.
Yeah, I know. I like I like I like your
religion. Can I join it?
Brother, hold on, let me explain. We
didn't we didn't uh have that yet. Not
yet, not yet, but you're planning on it,
right?
>> [laughter]
>> Well, I'm not planning, no.
Okay, bro. Does she live in the same
vicinity as you? I'm trying to find the
Hold on.
Does she live in the same vicinity as
you or she live in another country?
Uh yeah, yeah, she lives here.
Oh, I see, man.
So, and is she a strict Muslima?
Like her mom?
>> No.
No, no, no, no. Why can't I find this?
Okay, cuz I can't find this page, man.
Hold on. I'm trying to find the page,
but you know, life sucks for me. Okay,
so she's not a strict Muslima.
And you've been with her for a year.
They Well, anyway, brother, you're
already in sin, but I can't find the
page, brother. Hold on, man. I'm trying
to find the page so I can
This is why I hate my life sometimes. Do
you hate your life?
Not really.
You know, cuz I I hate your life. It's
okay?
Hold on, brother. Just let me find this.
Can you forgive me?
Let me take you.
>> of course. You forgive me?
For your sin?
Okay. Let me show you what that is.
Can you forgive me for your sin?
Okay. For my sin? Yeah, yeah. Cuz I want
to go to the priest and say,
"Forgive me, Father, for he has sinned."
But it's my fault he sinned.
You like that one? Okay, here's Here's
what the Bible tells you, my friend. You
ready?
Yeah. All right, let me go. Hold on.
This poor woman, you deceive her cuz she
thinks you're good-looking, sweet
talker, make her love fall in love with
you, and then you can't marry her. And
now you break her heart. Why are you
like this, man?
Why you do this to other people's
daughters?
Can you explain that to me?
Uh is that question to me? No, it's to
my mother over here. Mother!
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
Why you make her fall in love with you?
Why you make her
want to be with you when in her religion
she can't marry a non-Muslim and your
religion you cannot marry a
non-Christian?
Uh because uh I want her to come to
light, you know. I know. So, you
couldn't find you a Christian woman.
You had to find your Muslim woman and
say, "God, please
uh help me out here.
I want out whether she's Muslim and I
sinned against you, but do me a favor.
You know, you're a very gracious God.
Make her Christian so I can marry her."
Boss, two things.
She cannot marry a non-Muslim
in a Muslim society. And if she has some
fanatical relatives
that are crazy, she becomes Christian
for you, if they're fanatical, they will
harm her. So, you're putting her in
danger.
But, here's the verses for you. Do not
be unequally yoked with unbelievers.
For what partnership have righteousness
[clears throat] and lawlessness? So, you
see this part? Unequally yoked, you are
not to join yourself with unbelievers.
For what [snorts] partnership has
righteousness and lawlessness?
What fellowship has light with darkness?
>> [clears throat]
>> What harmony has Christ with Belial, the
name of Satan?
Baal. And all of the Quran is Baal.
Or what has a believer in common with an
unbeliever? Or what agreement has Sorry.
I know it's
just cats killing me.
>> [snorts]
>> A sanctuary of God with idols? For we
are a sanctuary of the living God.
Just as God [clears throat] said, "I
dwell in the I will dwell in them and
walk among them.
And I [clears throat] will be their God.
They shall be my people. Therefore, come
out from their midst
and be separate," says the Lord.
"And do not touch what is unclean.
And I will welcome you and I'll be a
father to you and you shall will sons
and daughters to me," says the Lord
Almighty. So, there you go, brother.
You're not supposed to be with her.
So, what are you going to do about it?
>> [snorts]
>> Um
well,
I'm going to
Of course, he breaks up with her, but
I was
>> [laughter]
>> I was I was hoping that
>> brother? Laugh. I'm going to leave her
now.
>> [laughter]
>> No, no. But, I was hoping that uh there
is something in the Bible that uh would
help like with the with the transition
uh hard transition.
But,
you know, you you you love this woman?
Yeah, of course.
You're going to break up.
You're going to break up with her for 5
minutes. That's it, I'm done. Sweetie, I
miss you. Can you come cook me some
shish kebab?
Okay.
You're not supposed to be with her, but
invite her so I can show her why Islam
is false.
Do you want me to at least talk to her
for you?
Uh no, she's not
uh right now here, but I will show the
video.
>> stuck for Allah.
You can tell her, "Come, let's talk to
this guy. He's very bold and handsome.
He's fatter than before, but he's still
handsome.
And he'll show you why you should become
Christian."
Yeah. Do you want me talk to her or no?
No, she really is not here. Okay,
brother. You're good man.
You got my email there, right?
Uh your email? In the private chat, you
little bald-headed freak.
Are you bald?
Uh I'm too young to be bald, but I'm
getting there. Yeah, but you sound bald.
Anyway, so you have my private chat
there.
Uh do you see it, the email?
Yes, yes, I have it. Don't delay it.
Say, "I want you talk to this man why
Islam is false." Maybe I can
be used of God so she become Christian
and when she become Christian she dump
you.
You know why?
No, why? Cuz when she comes to become
Christian and she knows Christianity she
goes, "Wow,
this is Christianity and I'm with this
loser?
I'm out of here. I'm going to go find me
a Christian who's on fire."
Okay?
Okay, I guess.
I didn't understand that quite, but uh
okay.
>> Let's try it again.
Right now you want her to be Christian.
When she becomes a Christian and she
knows what Christianity is, she's going
to say, "Wait, wait.
Now that I know what Christianity is
and you're supposed to be a Christian,
you're not supposed to go out with a
non-Christian.
That means you suck. I'm going to go
find me a real Christian man." See,
that's why. So, let her come talk to me,
okay?
Mhm, yeah.
Right?
Yes. Okay, brother. What's your name?
Victor. Victor.
I know you want to have victory in this
marriage, but you're going to have to
accept defeat.
To the victor goes the spoils.
Okay.
Email me when she wants to talk, okay?
Okay. Thank you very much. God bless
you. Let me know it's you. Say, "Hey,
I'm that bald guy, Victor, who made a
Muslim woman fall in love with me and I
know I suck, but we're ready to talk to
you."
Okay, I got you. You good man. How old
are you, brother?
I'm in April 22. 22? You don't sound a
day over six.
Really? No, yeah. You're very young in
the brain, but we love you, brother.
What nationality?
I'm uh Macedonian. Macedonian, huh? Yak
she mesh.
How? It's your language. I'm sorry. I
said yak she mesh.
Okay, brother.
>> No problem, no problem. God bless you,
brother.
God bless you, too. Thank you.
You want to make Christianity fun at the
same time, right? As you're rebuking
people
out of love without making them feel
like garbage. You make fun and laugh
because listen bre- brethren,
we all struggle.
Every one of us. I struggle. God saved
me from my lustful impurities. May he
destroy our struggle with sexual
impurities. It's a struggle even with a
Christian man and a Christian woman to
stay pure.
You guys who are single, you know.
The longer you're with a Christian man
or a Christian woman, the harder it is
to stay pure and not touch each other
until marriage. The Lord Jesus have
mercy on us and forgive us. May we
confess and acknowledge and Lord have
mercy. This is why I pray the Lord will
protect this young lady, keep her in her
continent until opens the door for
marriage and forgive us. It's hard, man.
Okay. Are we ready?
Let's say the Lord's prayer so we can
begin.